en fait ces trois semaines que que chez
publics ont été au courant que florent
pagny avait un cancer à prendre un grave
est en fait c'est vrai que j'ai beaucoup
tergiversé parce que pour moi il ya
quand même le secret médical je sais
bien sûr moment voilà on s'en fiche un
peu du secret médical mais moi j'ai pas
voulu le sortir et avec des contacts je
savais qu'il allait en parler cette
semaine
non il devait en parler un peu plus tard
donc nous on avait décidé comme on
savait qu'il allait en parler cette
semaine de sortir l'info que ce vendredi
afin de pas voilà révéler les choses
avant lui d'accord alors juste
aujourd'hui
fête qui vous le saviez depuis quand et
si c'est parce qu'en fait il à florent
il a appris florent pagny a apprise par
une amie à florent pagny a appris qu'il
avait un cancer des ponts début janvier
mi-janvier c'est
rendue chez un spécialiste à paris avec
sa femme a su sénat pour savoir un peu
quel type de traitement si c'était hop
et rap si ça ne m'était pas
et puis ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'il
enregistrait les dernières émissions ce
vendredi de d box que donc il le savait
quand tu leur en ville avait il savait
qu'il avait un cancer des poumons mais
il savait pas voilà de quelle était
l'ampleur quand il enregistrait en
russie il est au coin de voile a en fait
ce qui s'est passé que ça ce vendredi-là
reçues donc les résultats du spécialiste
qui avait été voir qu'un jour à avant et
là bas il découvre en fait que ce cancer
inopérable
le téléphone sonne pendant
l'enregistrement dans le mandarine et
voilà et en enregistrons d'eau et oui et
du cou et du coup ils décrochent et il a
il apprend la mauvaise nouvelle le
verdict tombe le cancer est inopérable
voilà cependant aux russes après
reprendre le tournage et reprend le
tournage donc il en parle avec les jurés
avec nikos voilà et puis là tout le
soutien c'est un battant florent pagny
et et reprend il finir l'enregistrement
le dernier enregistrement de de voice